Kirkland brand sells 39 billion dollars
of products so brand list people don't
know they went out of business what they
were trying to do was they were like
look don't pay for the name brand you
should just have high quality products
and they should just be brand less and
because we take away the name brand we
can lower the price that was like the
initial promise or the premise of the
business awesome idea
awesome idea I'm glad you said that
because a lot of you are [__] on
them now because they like failed but I
still think [__] awesome idea and
actually of course ironically brand less
is a great brand and so I think that was
really cool
they raised a [__] ton of money from
Softbank like two hundred million
dollars before they really achieved any
product market fit and that sort of like
was the death note for the company
because it was just um the expectations
when you raised two hundred million is
you're gonna be you know a billion
dollar plus company and if you do that
too early and you haven't actually
proven out your model you haven't
figured it all out what expectations
crush the business I actually so I
didn't prepare because I just thought
about this but what do you what's the
biggest grocery store chain in America
you think Albertsons maybe Safeway I
don't know okay let's see Safeway can
you look up try and find this just just
a headline trying to tell me what the
revenue or how many sales like generic
brands for grocery stores or like the
Kirkland brand or woke up how much
revenue the Kirkland brand does well I
mean I bet you it's astronomical and so
actually I would I mean if you think
about what brand list could become it is
the generic the generic trusted Kirkland
brand yeah I think and I think it's a
great idea yeah the problem was that
they raised all that money right off the
bat I have a problem there was some
incompetence with leadership I don't
actually know this yeah Kirkland brand
sells thirty nine billion dollars of
products Henry quick with the trigger I
like yeah one source what's the so you
think he's lying you think he's making
this up Wow
thirty eight billion dollars in one year
so so one thing I loved is I
okay and that's just Kirkland Kirkland
crazy so I listen to her on a podcast
Tina Sharkey I think this one and she's
like an Internet
Oh G she'd been around with a bunch of
companies all of which I think have not
done super great but she went on this
podcast she said this thing that I liked
which was she was like think back to
when you were a child and like let's
walk from room to room you're in the
laundry room what brand are you gonna
see you're gonna see whatever ya tied
you're gonna see whatever go to the
pantry what are you gonna see you're
gonna see fruit roll-up and Pop Tarts
and all this stuff and then open up your
fridge what are you gonna see and you
see these brands and actually it's kind
of like you've seen these stats where
the S&P 500 turns over like I don't know
20% of the S&P 500 turns over every
every decade basically the same thing
happens with these are household brands
these brands that seem like staples of
your home right a lot of them are like
like Minute Maid it's like [__] Minute
Maid you're out like you know now you
know tang yeah Tang you know like these
brands just like like they are not they
can come and go generationally they
don't all make it from one mom to the
next mom and I actually believe that
premise and she was like look the moms
of this generation they don't want to
pay for this like the consumer packaged
goods and in the same way they want out
no it's high-quality ingredients sourced
you know ethically and you know they
don't want to overpay they want to be
you know value conscious so I liked a
lot of premise I'm sad I didn't work but
somebody I believe I believe you should
just go out today and pitch
I'm bran list without Softbank and I
think I would I would invest in a
credible entrepreneur I agree with you I
think I had three people reach out to me
that said hey can you ask can you
introduce me to the people who are
selling for a unless I mean I don't know
them but I just tweeted it and I got an
intro and I introduced three different
people who are wanting to buy the assets
now written what are the what are the
assets what are you getting you get the
name maybe a little inventory probably
okay the name and email list and then
unfortunately probably a bunch of an
incompetent team right no disrespect but
look at the couldn't pull it off there
by definition
well you'll you'll need to restart for
sure right you'll need a clean slate and
you need to lower the burn yeah I think
it's cool I would
charge of new membership they did a
subscription because they started off
with everything was three bucks I forgot
to mention that that was like a key
selling points like everyone's three
bucks looks like three dollar store and
people say the CAC was too high they
cost too much to acquire customers
that's probably true but like wish is
doing it
[Music]